die Deutschen lieben ist zu Grill sobald
die ersten Sonnenstrahlen auf der Haut
kitzeln bewegen sich deutsche Väter wie
ferngesteuert in den Garten aber grillen
ist nicht gleich Barbecue und kaum an
einem Ort wird Barbecue so sehr
zelebriert wie in den USA ich habe ein
Restaurant gefunden in dem es Barbecue
vom Smoker gibt wie in den USA lass uns
gemeinsam herausfinden was es so gut
macht und warum zwei Jungs aus Dormagen
es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht haben das
nach Deutschland zu bringen eine lange
Straße die scheinbar ins Nirgendwo führt
wir sind nicht an der Route 66 nein wir
sind in Dormagen und hier drüben ist weg
Barbecue wir sind endlich da no joke
direkt von Anfang an ein surrealer Ort
es ist einfach krass da steht der Smoker
er Smoker auch er tut was er soll davon
sitzen auch schon die beiden Jungs und
ich freue mich auf alles was wir heute
erzählt bekommen was wir schmecken was
wir erleben es wird geil los geht's
gebracht haben weil wir heute zu Gast
sein dürfen sind die Jungs einige der
ersten die die blockprodukte bekommen
hallo Erik hallo ihr seid die ersten den
ich das übergebe okay meine eigene
friend ist bald startet könnt ihr in
Ruhe mal reingucken
sagte irgendwas
[Gelächter]
schon von dem Brett was aufheben muss
wenn man von A nach B benutzen
[Gelächter]
Spülmaschine
ich würde sagen kommen wir erstmal an
und schauen wir mal was wir hier alles
erleben können
wir uns erstmal um hier
[Musik]
die beiden Jungs sind am big Hack
Barbecue sind Tim und Kai Tim kommt aus
der Gastronomie Kompetenz und Erfahrung
aus dem Küchenalltag Erdogan der
Sterneküche gearbeitet und Kai ist der
Barbecue Fanatiker der die Barbecue
Komponente bringt während sein Bruder
alle Soßen und Zeit selbst macht
selbstgemachtes übrigens im Stichwort
dass wir später noch häufiger hören
werden Notebook der Laden hat so viel
Charakter das ist wirklich ein
Restaurant wie kein anderes das ist auch
kein Biergarten auch wenn es ein
bisschen Züge von einem Biergarten hat
oder so Dachterrasse unten den Smoker
stehen innen drin ist so ein bisschen so
Sportlerheim und so aber es ist
irgendwie trotzdem direkt so ein
wohlfühling man weiß alles was hier
außenrum ist wird um das Produkt gebaut
das Produkt haben wir jetzt schon
gemerkt ist Ihnen auf jeden Fall
verdammt wichtig und dafür machen sie
auch einiges die Jungs sind Pioniere des
deutschen Street foods waren auch
verschiedenen Festivals mit ihrem Smoker
unterwegs deshalb steht der Smoker auch
heute noch auf einem Wagen und man hat
das Gefühl dass die einfachen natürlich
reingewachsen sind also sie haben
einfach gutes Essen gemacht so gut dass
sie es anderen Leuten auf dem Festival
Angebot haben und so gut dass es jetzt
auch im Restaurant gibt wir können uns
schon ein bisschen umschauen Kai Tim ich
habe einige Fragen an euch die
allererste stundenlange smoken bis ins
kleinste Detail macht ihr alles selbst
warum es soll also authentisch sein ja
man muss auch Spaß dran haben ne also
wir haben uns nicht zusammengesetzt und
überlegt wie kriegt man jetzt auf 1 € am
besten zwei hin und unsere
Grundüberlegung war einfach wir wollen
geil Kochen ich möchte was kochen wo ich
dahinter stehe was mir Spaß macht ist zu
kochen und wenn das Leute geil finden
Glück gehabt wow also das finde ich
wirklich bewundernswert was ist so dein
gastronomischer background wäre in
Mönchengladbach gemacht für mich eben
Sachen selber machen zu wollen und
danach auch in sterneküchen unterwegs
gewesen nicht nur auch und von Sylt ist
ein bisschen unterwegs
oder genau
Gastronomie keine Küchen background
sondern von dir kommt quasi die Passion
smoken und von dir kommt die Passion
Küche wenn ich hier den Apparat sehe wo
kann ich sonst Smoker kaufen kann ich
dir bauen lassen vom Kumpel das ist
nicht genau das brauche ich nach Hause
die Dinger gibts nicht du kannst großes
Walker bauen lassen und kaufen
selbstverständlich man kann die aber
auch selber machen ja also Offset
reverse Flow und ähm reverse Flow
bedeutet nichts anderes als wir den
Rauch erstmal unter dem Garten gut von
der Feuerkammer bis nach hinten leiten
und erst dann geht's übers Jahr gut
wieder raus aus dem Schornstein aber ich
habe mal einfach eine größere nutzbare
Fläche im Smoker weil dann hier nicht zu
heiß ist und da hinten nicht zu kalt im
Grunde ist der kalte Spot jetzt genau
hier in der Mitte da ist relativ warm da
ist relativ warm aber immer noch so
davon mehr oder weniger vollständig
nutzen kann
also hier wird Pulver bearbeiten die
Schweineschulter mit Knochen mit
fettdeckel ganz wichtig liegt jetzt hier
relativ warm weil Schwein ganz gut mit
Hitze umgehen kann hier haben wir die
Spareribs guthahn
eine riechen könntet was wir hier
riechen ich glaube dann würdet ihr durch
den Bildschirm springen und einfach
alles essen ich freue mich auch schon
wieder darauf wie oft kann man bei euch
essen gehen von Freitag bis Sonntag das
ist nämlich auch ein Ding einfach nur am
Wochenende weil es nicht anders geht
weil so viel Vorbereitung nötig ist
verschiedene Bedingungen einfach wir
haben äh wir haben eine sehr kleine
Küche und ähm bei dem anderen gehen wir
mittlerweile haben ist es dann nicht
mehr möglich in der kleinen Küche auch
nebenbei zu produzieren also muss man
das ein bisschen auslagern das heißt
heute Donnerstag wir produzieren auch in
der Küche und den Rest derzeit versuchen
wir dann zu schicken ja eine letzte
Frage stell ich mir die mother ist für
mich so der Barbecue Traum also wenn ich
daran denke alles was ich darauf liegen
habe was gehört eigentlich alles dazu
was ist alles dabei ich meine wir haben
natürlich ein paar von den Sachen die
wir hier gesehen aber auch die Zeit noch
was ist bei euch auf Platte drauf ja das
entscheidest Du selber du suchst ja
selber deine fünf favorite Fleischsorten
raus aus der Karte von 7 dann haben wir
die Beilagen wo du frei wählen kannst
und auch Soßen die du auch selbst
bestimmen kannst also du entscheidest
was auf dem Wasser drauf ist was sind
eure besten Sachen Rippchen muss
natürlich sein was tramy kommst du nicht
dran vorbei ich würde sagen der ist
richtig geil kommt immer gut jetzt durch
den Truthahn schon wieder Unrecht weil
ich ihn zuletzt erwähne ich glaube wenn
ihr irgendwas nicht gut finden würde
würdet ihr euch nicht die ganze Mühe
machen
dann macht mir die beste Motte die ich
je gegessen habe ich freue mich so
darauf die ganze Gerüchte das ganze
warten es wird so lecker da ist so place
magic happen wichtig ist dass du ein
schönes Feuer hast was die ganze Zeit
durch brennt nicht aus geht nicht zu
heiß brennt wichtig ist dass es nicht
ausgeht da weil sobald der Feuer wenig
brennt mehr rauchentwickelt und du
willst so wenig Rauch wie nur irgendwie
möglich beim smoken haben wirklich
willst kein Qualm weil das was hier geil
nach Holz riecht ist das was was wir
hier gerade riechst und hier ist kaum
Rauch und das macht die Würze aus das
wichtige bei dem Feuer oder beim smoken
ist das Feuer nichts anderes kein Rap
Fleisch ist auch noch super wichtig eine
Sache ist mir bewusst geworden Barbecue
hat nichts mit Minutensteaks zu tun denn
kai ist wirklich alle 30 Minuten von
seinem Wagen zum Smoker gegangen hat
Holz nachgelegt das Feuer kontrolliert
und einfach ganz ganz ganz viel Zeit und
Liebe investiert für sein Produkt und
der Geruch war kaum auszuhalten also wir
waren den ganzen Tag da aber
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir den Geruch
nicht ausgeblendet sondern je näher man
sich zum Smoker bewegt hat desto
intensiver wurde das Verlangen endlich
zu essen und irgendwann war's dann noch
endlich soweit
[Musik]
und wie immer ganz wichtig ohne Fähnchen
schmecken nicht
[Musik]
oder wie krank ist das unglaublich nach
diesem Tag nachdem wir so viel darüber
erfahren haben nachdem wir verstanden
haben wie viel Liebe hier drin steckt
das jetzt in der Hand zu halten und vor
allem essen zu dürfen unglaublich
wirklich sterbe wenn ich das jetzt nicht
probiere guckt euch diese Pracht an
Leute es ist wirklich kaum auszuhalten
hier drüber zu sitzen wir haben alles
was wir heute gesehen haben alles was
wir heute gelernt haben vor mir auf der
doppelten motherplatte ich glaube das
ist wirklich ja das ist total also das
ist auch natürlich nicht für eine Person
gedacht wenn ihr das so bestellt hatte
kriegt ihr auch genau das alles
feinstens abgewogen ich probiere mich
jetzt durch und ich fange an mit ich
weiß nicht
mehr rein
ich freue mich so dass ich das essen
darf
boah ist ein bisschen Essig dabei und
der hat wirklich so eine ganz schöne
fruchtige Note die er mit rein bringt
boah das ist so eine Geschmack der
Explosion gerade ich bin auch seit
Stunden fokussiert auf dieses Barbecue
und jetzt probieren zu können sollte es
dir nicht nur vorstellen müssen
und alles daran ist so ein
amerikanischer Traum auch so dieses dick
geschnittene angetastete Brot ja mit
Butter probier mal diese kartoffelbruder
richtig krass gemacht muss vorstellen
einfach eine Ofenkartoffeln dann kommt
da so ein halbes Kilo Butter rein
Streukäse und dann wird darauf ein
draus gemacht in der Kartoffel oben
drauf vielleicht noch eine Bechamel
das wirklich perversberry ich gehe rein
Muster source Carolina mastered alle
Soßen selbst gemacht ich weiß nicht ich
denke warum ist es so lernen im
Hintergrund wir sind da an dem Tag an
den Jungs gar nicht auf haben damit wir
entspannt drehen können haben wir das
alles so gemacht weil sonst ist ja
verständlicherweise die Hölle los man
schmeckt wirklich dieses Holz das ist so
krank
es geht um Holzaroma und das was man
hier riecht wenn man hier vom Laden mit
dem Auto passt das schmeckt man selten
riecht man etwas und das schmeckt dann
so wie es riecht das hier riecht so geil
wie es schmeckt und es schmeckt sogar
wie es riecht also mit der originalen
Flagge drin ich gehe rein boah auch hier
wieder richtig cremig richtig dick
weil Makkaroni
boah die sind wirklich so schön cremig
ja noch nicht mal davon gehört von Cream
das klingt aber schon hart rechts
Zwiebeln Bechamelsoße Mais wie soll das
nicht schmecken auch in diesem Beilagen
steckt halt so viel Liebe drin das
Zusammenspiel ist es ist
nicht gedacht dass jemand sagen würde
aber ich muss öfters nach sauber machen
also wirklich Jungs Respekt
Heftigkeit jetzt verstehe ich alles so
nice ich kann euch jetzt noch minutiös
zu einem sagen wie es schmeckt aber ich
glaube die kurze Antwort ist sehr sehr
gut vielleicht beenden wir das Video mit
einem bis in die Spareribs
[Musik]
ich habe heute gelernt warum Barbecue
richtig geil ist wir sehen uns im
nächsten Video wieder macht's gut bis
dahin ciao